hello everyone this next game is like no
other you've seen on my channel it's a
very special game because in this game
well no pieces were captured by either
side and no checks were given also by
either side this game was played in a
very strong tournament in Palma de
Majorca in Spain in 1968 and well the
winner of this tournament was a Viktor
Korchnoi it was a one of a precaution as
best tournaments ever as he drew the
world champion Tigran Petrosian and he
defeated Boris Spassky and a lot of
strong players like Larson and League
Ridge and this game I'm going to show
you is played between Antonio Medina
Garcia and slitaz ugly glitch and like I
said although Viktor Korchnoi won the
tournament and the gligar each one fifth
place behind the
Petrosyan Larson and I think it was a
spot yes I this game licorice plate is
definitely the one to want to see so
well without further ado let's let's see
this game Antonio Garcia is white and
cytostatic [ __ ] rich is black so we
have E 4 E 5 9 2 s 3 9 2 c6 Bishop to b5
the real Lopez or the Spanish opening we
have a 6 the Morsi defense we should pay
for Knight to f6
Garcia castles and here the legal
displays the Bishop to e7 bleaker rich
ebony George could have placed something
like nice captures on e4 and this is
what pretty standard also but after rook
to e1 and 95 and maybe Bishop captures
on c6 d captures and c6 and night
captors on e5 the tension in the center
is gone and Google which doesn't want to
allow this as of course he considers
himself to be the stronger player so he
would like to preserve the tension and
he plays Bishop d7 so he has rook to e1
v 5 by will rich Bishop to b3 b6 c3
glitch castles h3 h 6d for rook to e8
nice B to d2 this Knight is preparing
for a very long maneuver for example d2
to f12 maybe
3 or g3 and then to maybe f5 so we have
Bishop to f8 nice to f1 Bishop d7 and
now nice the g3 Garcia has a pretty good
plan as the blue Cody she has already
played h6 this kind of weekends he had
five square because if Garcia manages to
put his knight on f5 gligar each can't
really get it out of the square except
maybe by playing g6 but I would further
weaken his games position or simply by
retreating his Bishop to c8 so we have
nine so a five by blue garage attacking
this strong Bishop
we have Bishop to see to Knight to c4
now Bishop to d3 quicker plays Knight to
be six and this is all pretty standard
black is preparing c5 we have Bishop to
d2 and now c5 by acreage and b5 by
Garcia he wants to close the position we
have a bishop to c8
now also protecting that f5 square we
have B 3 C 4 attacking the bishop bishop
to F 1 and Bishop to d7 we have an eye
to h2 Garcia wants to push f4 so we have
a route to see 8 B 4
also further closing the position Knight
to a4 and Queen to f3 and al Garcia is
planning to play Knight to f5 because
another Queen is protecting here and if
you would very much enjoy trading this
night for this slide square bishop
because this light square bishop is a
good piece the glittery chess on the
other hand this dark square bishop is
not another very good piece well not yet
so we have g6 bigwig original along the
night to go to f5 Bishop to e2 we have
Bishop to g7 h4 preparing to push h5 to
you know further weaken DF v square so
we have 92 h7 and now if you pushes h5
googlers plays Knight to g5 attacking
the Queen and we have a queen to e3 and
now Google it pushes f5 and already well
black is like is much better here
as his his pawn structure is now
perfectly fine the set five movies is
really really good and he's preparing to
push at four you know the two kind of
for the the queen in the night and
capturing this at five point with pretty
much achieve nothing as he would simply
recapture G capture some f5 and still
still the threat of f4 would would
remain in it would only weaken the d5
pawn that White has so Garcia tries a
well as the Queen a seven move and there
wasn't really any place for the Queen to
go he could have removed the knife but
the Queen is pretty vulnerable on e3 so
we have f4 by we're rich and nice to f1
by Garcia and now really go to a place
work to a attacking the Queen and also
protecting this a6 pawn we have Queen -
b7 by Garcia and now Glee Girish plays
rook to e7 and in this position antonio
media medida garcia resigned the game as
there is no defense against the bishop
to e8 for example whatever white plays
and what what doesn't really have a good
move here for example if H captures and
g6 and simply Bishop to EA tanned the
queen is trapped so even without
capturing the spawn girl Antonio Garcia
decided to resign the game and well this
so it with the you know become a part of
history as no no pieces were captured
and the no checks were given by either
side and some people even call this game
the Liga richest bughouse immortal
because like as no checks were given and
no pieces were captures they might have
might as well as I've even played back
house it would still be the same game so
yeah that's the game I hope you enjoyed
that I believe this is my first game I
featured settler gligar rich on my
channel but I will do more games as he
is a fantastic player and yeah that's it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching I
will see you soon